good morning Mel young president of the
homeless World Cup social entrepreneur
here at the final day of the World
Economic Forum summit in Vienna it's
been a fascinating couple of days
innovation is the key theme of the
conference and it's quite clear that
there's an optimistic mood here with
people talking about all sorts of
possibilities for connectivity across
Europe in particular looking at
connections into Central Asia so there
are many problems and challenges facing
European economy at the moment which is
affecting many millions of people but it
seems that there's opportunities and
people are talking about how the current
problems can be surmounted so it's very
very positive mood here and I think
people will be taking away from here
many ideas many new connections from my
own point of view I'm very passionate
about social innovation so innovation
just isn't about technical issues or
economic issues it's about people and
there's been a huge amount of discussion
about social innovation about where
social innovation fits next to future
plans across Europe and the wider
Central Asia region so some very very
interesting discussions you can't have a
sustainable economy unless it includes
all the people this is what I am
passionate about and other people are
passionate about and I think it's coming
through strongly here people are
recognizing that if we're going to move
forward the only way you can create a
proper and fair economy as if what
everyone's included and so therefore
social innovation as an absolutely key
role to play